Ah ah ah
[music]
Come on Rashaishali This is the song and dance of the revolving group, how beautiful it is, but
this dance everywhere is wonderful
[music]
Kaho can now sing and Kitani can dance  It was really good After the
heat wave
er, I think it's a lot for two cars to turn one
[Music]
Nodding hips are Zone The
common people's food is pretty good, isn't it bad?  The e-girls
who seem to have lost their colors around the world,
oh, oh
[music]
I'll read it out
aname Jack The men's and women's meat dishes are the best, but I'm satisfied with the taste
of my mouth  If the inside is no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no n  This is the song at all, isn't
it?  I'm going to go to the nail salon right now
Graffa, everyone, don't be afraid, buy it